[Music]
welcome back to the morning toast today
is Wednesday May 8th happy birthday Lisa
and just you know another day in the car
as a cog in the toastie machine you know
yeah that's the life we live better than
my ears I can hear it moving around you
know it's better than most other
machines I have a migraine I have a cold
I have allergies
once one illness ends another one begins
I'm baring legs today feeling very
vulnerable I just caught myself on the
camera I just think I want to really
look cute you look at you're gonna play
tennis thank you well Jill and LuAnn so
here's here's what happened to me when
it pertains to this rubber I think
that's what did a story last night so I
have a fake Instagram account in which I
look at all these like bloggers and like
celebrities that like I like love and
hate and like just don't want them to
see like girls no jobs watching their
stories not that I think I'm so great
you know but like the verified checkmark
I just like I'm not trying to draw
attention to myself and I was talking
about on the show how like I was
recently becoming like heavily
influenced by one of these girls like I
just followed because she's so cringy
but then I'm like you know what I love
her so he started following her and now
one of the other girls that I followed
just like to like see like to cringe
I've also become heavily influenced by
Urban's by her clothes like that's crazy
I bought this in a sway pub you're
making her money I'm making her maybe
you know what she deserves it she has a
great taste for a low budget that's so
interesting I should follow more
bloggers I really don't follow like any
bloggers
I've just been finding myself needing
clothes for this like we always start
saying her like we don't have enough
just blouses cuz we wear them on the
show and then like you become so aware
of how frequently you wear something
because you do a show every day and you
film it yeah so it's been really helpful
like this romper was like 60 bucks I
literally know it's 48 how I look today
because I woke up this morning with a
migraine and then like I did my makeup
and then I sat on my bed like Tiffany
Pollard and that meme
drinking my coffee just like waiting to
feel better and it didn't happen that
was literally me watching Zakia ready we
do look very like NSYNC today like we
are going to the country club or like
the wasp Association of America yeah
yeah the annual meeting aka the country
cover price yeah you know it there's
worse there's worse looks out there
anyways I was like hopefully more people
will listen as a
test today because I'm just not feeling
lilyc Podcast e vibes so now everyone's
gonna tune in who's listening to podcast
to see how you know doe just looking for
the hyper edited vote photo on Instagram
later today hey um so we had a great
presale yesterday I mean just I think of
the headspace I was in yesterday verse
today it's like I feel so much lighter
that's why I'm wearing this very brave
outfit with my period I have my period
today can you believe I'm wearing this
that is bravery my friend day 30 so like
I might be okay oh not so not so brave
and I just like kind of pit in my
stomach yesterday and now it's just like
I sold like 70% of the tickets at the
weekend like that's so crazy like so
crazy it's so crazy I'm just like
feeling relaxed and everyone like on the
team was like second show I'm like get
away from me like don't even look at me
with that second show mindset okay like
Chicago maybe New York get the hell out
of here get the hell out totally
oh that's so no you can rot inhale like
what's the point of cell like it's like
you only sell out just to be a loser
accomplishment Jack and I know just four
more work that is truly and in life my
cross to bear because like you know when
you're like an manager an agent like
your goal is always like the most money
like I'm going to Chicago for the night
like let's make you the most possible
money but I'm just like vain and I'm
like no I want everyone to think I sold
out like one show not like shelling
tickets for the second show you know how
you did like five shows that the Rose
would write rosewood where Pretty Little
Liars is filmed Rosemont
but yeah no but rosewood is Pretty
Little Liars yeah but I performed at
Rosemont like it's not correct pray for
us today you guys um I just like I can't
with the migraines and what's really
frustrating is like we go on these trips
like we're working so hard and every
time we go away I'm so nervous I'm gonna
get a migraine at like the worst
possible time in the middle of
stagecoach you imagine having a migraine
oh my god horrible and I never have a
migraine then they come home and I'm
like you know I'm gonna get back to it
working out eating healthy and they get
hit struck down with the migraine it's a
God doesn't want you to either know or
it's like something that I'm doing my
body is allergic to I have two things to
say what are the migraine front I
totally feel that and can you ask me
what the worst place to get a migraine
is before show uh in Boston which was
like my biggest show I got a migraine
before it ended up being the biggest
blessing I was talking like it's such a
normal pace just because like my head
kind of her and I was like a little
tired and I
performing so well cause like I was just
like edit for me I was slow but like for
normal people I was just like a regular
person
second thing is I really think like just
from the bottom my heart like we need to
stop using the shows a platform to
complain about our illnesses I think
I've become so hyper aware of it this
week cuz I got your cold and we're both
just like recovering but it's just I
can't imagine that it's like pleasant to
listen to - nasally kids talk about
their rivalry okay but one it's a sick
week and two when I have a migraine on
the show I just want to put it out there
just in case people are like she's so
low in or like Erika Jayne yeah like I
don't you watch Beverly Hills I did what
I did we'll talk about everything so I'm
just like it's more so like a cautionary
tale like if you're not pleased with my
performance in today's episode just know
that I have a migraine go easy on me
that's all I'm saying
I understand all I'm saying you know
I'll just since you're usually the one
talking so much more like I'll today
just try and like you know amp it up a
little bit that's so us that is so us
well I'm still excited me too I gave a
meeting today which like whatever but I
was told that the meeting is taking
place across the street from like this
fantastic I've been digging about a
jaggies since Olivia told me this fans
have two things Olivia told me across
the street is a Chipotle that Olivia
said she's had the best fountain soda
she's ever had in her life she gets it
every day
does it have it did he include it or did
he not include clear if you're a new
toaster you know that the first time you
and Jackie ever a Chipotle first and
last well okay interesting interesting
arc in that story first time you Jackie
ever a diarrhea was actually the first
time me and Jackie ever a Chipotle me
also a diarrhea there like we were both
eating and we were like are you teasing
area because I'm tasting diarrhea like
even in the soda I taste diary
I mean if it was diary tour or duty
diary taken that rich margarita
therapist diary or duty so I just I
don't want to like speak to the
clinician speak oh man I don't sure the
condition that someone might or might
not have had it was like it was when we
were I was an intern in college and you
were still working at AOL and like it
was Chipotle was like the most glam like
everyone was a trilogy well it's really
so right okay we got to see what all the
hype is about and there was one by the
office and we went and like we're just
looking at each other were like you're
juicing Diaries here right and I was
like yeah no you know how it started
we even walked into a Chipotle his
remember there used to be food ax where
there was like micro restaurants that
would come in to a well yeah and we got
really into Mo's southwestern bowls
because you like they had like it's a
thing where they go into companies and
they serve lunch and so you can really
make you could see it all and make your
own sweet would make our own little like
Mexican bowls and we were like wow we
love Mexican food yeah I guess we didn't
know like we were truly like Mexican
right we were loving Mexican food so we
got a little ahead of ourselves so we
should go to the motherland Chipotle so
we never we we truly like we never went
back until Myanmar go on the road we're
driving from South Carolina to North
Carolina after my show like in the
middle of the night and we weren't
starving for like a real meal not like
you know McDonald's
so we were looking on the map and the
only place open was Chipotle I was like
you know what let me give it another
shot like there has to be something to
it and that's exactly what I wanted like
fresh like food like I was actually
creating like vegetables so the driver
pulled over and we went in and me and
Margo got our food and we continued
driving right in the back of a car like
looking at each other and we're like
this is amazing I've had it now three
times since that's in South Carolina
it's and you know it's a good good
healthy option yeah what'd you put in it
but I just look girl chicken guacamole
oh nice maybe I'll have it today too
because apparently eating healthy is
just not in the cards oh yeah Olivia
said that across the street from where
we have our meeting today is a the most
amazing Chipotle but the best I cook and
be like this fancy ass stationery store
I've been waiting to get a new planner
and she's like it's the best notebooks
or I've even know what it's called it's
called paper source and it's a chain
like it's like papyrus it's not
indigenous that's not a lot of chains
but it's good for sure but it's like
papyrus it's it's paper so I'd be able
to find what I need I think so but I
think I should get my planner at a
glance
monthly I had had a glance monthly but
it's like in order to have it at a
glance monthly and then bring to your
at-a-glance monthly with you everywhere
it's like you have to bring a briefcase
it's like the tallest thing ever yeah so
I got a banjo one which was a toaster
recommendation and it's so [ __ ] cute
and toasty but it gave me the weirdest
months I've had it now June 2018 to
August 2019 why can't they just make it
January to December so you're on a
school calendar yeah so then I bought
the new banjo version on Amazon and I
ended up buying the same exact one with
the same exact dates and I have to if
anybody wants a [ __ ] planner for the
next two months yeah
so I just feel like going into store
I didn't plan or something really hard
to buy it online that's what I was gonna
say it is unless you know what you want
which is at a glance monthly which is
not I don't know I like a weekly and
monthly oh I don't I don't do weekly I
just need to see my month I need to see
my week I can't think that far in
advance why cuz I see my week with him
I'm on that's like the hardest thing
about going on tour like okay you want
to go to Chicago and oh yes I'm like how
do I know right
that's belonging right like you never
know where you're gonna be you're all my
torreón literally booked the flight like
the night before I mean that's just life
see okay
sneeze chest excuse me oh okay well are
you ready to get into the past five
stories manjo released their planners
today that's what someone in the
comments wrote like their new scholastic
year you don't mean Scholastic Year sure
that's sure well no now I'm stuck in
scholastic year no because I've only go
until August just get an annual but then
what do I do for August through December
he'll have to get a half of like a
planner that you'll needs half of you
got to get on track
I do yeah you got it it's time okay you
know what else it's time for yeah I
think so the fast side stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast that's
some great stories for you today because
first up Megan Merkel and Prince Harry
show royal baby for the first time they
stepped out with their leetle bita
Sussex still no name I mean Mellie
Bromley was on yesterday on daily pop
talking about the Markel's
and first of all she like really takes
umbrage with Thomas Merkel which makes
me like like him a little more until she
they literally couldn't even talk about
him what's your stake in this she was
getting so incensed well it's just crazy
that is Crittenden they were talking met
him for so long he's like let's change
the subject like triggered
she's triggered thought it was crazy so
I thought they were stepping out today
with a betta and a name still no name do
we have a gender boy boy okay but yeah
in predictions were boys yeah and I
think the top two name predictions now
are Arthur and Albert which I think it's
like a little cruel to name your baby
Albert you know what I just think is
cruel is the fact that like Buckingham
Palace demands that all the way within
their family like do a press conference
three days after giving birth it's like
[ __ ] I think I want to put on makeup
right now like I got a baby on my teeth
like leave me alone I got scars in my
badge
I just think that's so like not feminist
of them no it's it's really and that
works great I'm just saying I know she
don't want to be there she was for the
first time in her life
Megan Markov was walking away from press
when it was over she was like thank you
guys so much it was her who was like
Perry let's get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah no that's true torture like I can't
get up for anything like after a day of
a hangover like for a migraine yeah she
doesn't get like any maternity leave
yeah what the hell that is kind of and
they used to make Kate 2a2 after every
birthday like standing outside she's
like wearing her little petticoat it's
like hey but also let her go to sleep
when Kate you should do it she used to
leave the hospital and wave with the
bebut and like that was the scene of of
the baby for the first time yeah but
they did like a full-blown press
conference torture yeah but that seems
like they was their choice I think they
just wanted to do something different
than Kate right it was definitely
different background cos Kate was like
truly right outside the hospital they
look to be inside some sort of palace
yeah like this was a big ordeal with a
proper photographer and everything nice
ain't torture they made an extra extra
but she also seemed like she did want to
be there she was like get lit she
literally was like grabbing Harry's I'm
just like let's go yeah I mean how would
anyone even the the biggest there
sponsors of them all know I just need a
day off oh and Kate's has been on the
same day according to the toasters oh my
god
honestly like women can do everything
but like sometimes like let them do
nothing
I think that was cure Knightley's point
once remember she was saying like oh
yeah that Kate Middleton kind of was
setting like you know an unrealistic
expectation for women by stepping out of
the hospital the day after she gave
birth but she said oh god she said it
was what the problem was not that she
was stepping out was that she was
wearing makeup yeah and like she's like
this she's being forced to step out let
her at least wear makeup right make it
looks pretty two sides to the quinidine
totally agree with Carole Knightley but
that is what she was saying is I think
she got lost making her point cuz the
point I think she was trying to make is
a better point yeah which is just like
it's an unfair expectation for women you
know like you don't understand I don't
know anything about giving birth but I'm
hoping to be doing it sometime soon and
I just know I don't know a lot about
childbirth but I know that the day after
I gave birth I will not want to
literally come close to make up come
close to any human being who's not
directly related to me or leave my bed
so it's like I can't even imagine being
forced put on a dress with a belt make
up and go to our press conference know
like
you giving birth knock on wood she's
gonna be there I'm gonna be there but
like it's going to be I think the most
torturous painful loud screaming birth
of all time
no no history of women is such an
aversion to pain I think I like have to
get a c-section like I just I don't
think I can handle it is a c-section
less much less painful well you are on I
don't know what the drug is but it's
like you're awake but like loopy and
like you with no idea that like below
you they're just like it's cutting you
open they're taking out all your organs
and then putting them back in they don't
do this they do that's what I heard okay
I don't know who you talked to you but
that's not true I just cut the bidding
take the baby he said I heard they cut
it open they take out all your organs
they take out the baby and then they put
your organs back where they go and I go
make a name of operation was Megan Marko
like not to make things to burger but
[ __ ] you've been wearing like a pad or
something you bleed and you leak yeah
let her leak in peace okay like such
torture and you know she's such a
fabulous like I can't believe she would
let that happen
she was wearing white that is brave
that's [ __ ] Braves no it's like oh my
god I honestly have the utmost respect
for Meghan barkal today I mean in your
mind when you picture like you said you
like squeezing pushing giving birth
who's in the room and where are they
standing because I have thought this
through like 1,000% honestly I want to
be alone like no Zach even know like I
just you know me like at when I'm in
pain like I suffered through it in
silence and I'm I told you I'm Kimmy
Schmidt I'm like just get through the
next ten seconds next ten seconds so I
just wanted to be over with like I don't
want to make it a production I just want
to go in pregnant and come out with a
Bibbit and like I don't need you guys to
remember what you saw
oh we have no that's so mean I totally
want to be there here's what's gonna
happen
I want to be completely alone maybe just
mom I mean I can maybe just do her
energy and like and her at her expertise
okay in my mind here's how it goes
like I can't deal with you screaming
gotcha I want Olivia on actually no I
hear it I won't snitch on just like my
mice like slaved uni it's like I need
ice I need this like she's just like
freaking things back and forth for me I
need Olivia and mom up at the top
because they're very calming forces and
they're just like breathe relax chill
the [ __ ] out hi okay I want to hear what
you have in store for me
I want you filming at the bottom okay
but I and I want then in the other room
but I think
I am a calming force and I think no
offence is a little dramatic she is but
she's very like nurturing you don't have
that like real like like nurturing like
rubbing my belly type thing where like
Olivia would in my sweaty hair be
running her hand and like tickling my
back I would be like get the hell off me
doing my back well I've been giving
birth just like through the labor like
through the contrasting would you rub my
feet no Olivia would I would rub your
feet cuz feet are meant to be rubbed
okay you know I just I've thought a lot
about writing my hands through your hair
right no it's like you're really sweaty
and like put my hair in a bun because
I'm hot and my neck hurts em get me a
fan will you be there no I just don't
see you doing that and I would do a fan
it just depends I'm like Angry whatever
I've thought about it a lot and I had
never seen the friends episode know
where Ross is where Rachel spoiler alert
gives birth okay it's so funny like Ross
makes the whole thing about himself like
he gets hit in the head and as Rachel's
pushing is like oh you have no idea how
much this hurts I'm like everyone's
looking around you know and I actually
had seen that and that's been I know
Ben's gonna be he's been complaining all
week his elbows been hurting him cuz
he's been playing golf I just know he
buddy I'm like pushing with blood and
placenta coming out of my vagine and Ben
will be in the corner being like you
know my arm really hurts no no totally
he's or he'll be with his phone flash in
there totally I mean it is Kido season
very Kido season totally and where will
Theo be in the process probably your
arms
he'll probably be with Ben's parents
like right outside okay there he is
bringing it doctor hospitals like sevens
editor for sure but he needs to meet his
sibling like really like they need to
make that connection so quickly no I
think like I don't know if what about to
say is I couldn't be offensive to some
people be like I think it's really weird
and like borderline dangerous for people
who have dogs like let the dogs get so
close like a new fresh baby like even
though Theo is the most precious thing I
literally could shove my hand in Theo's
mouth and he would invite it still took
an animal and a precious child like so I
have a feeling I'll like one Theo to
stay at your place for like a week just
while I get acclimated to my new life
week out and then we'll slowly start
integrating Theo into the the babies
everyday life you know I just think I
think it's weird like there's those
pictures like I'm people now yeah
huge like me whatever it's called
Doberman yeah and like a tiny fresh week
old baby like I just am NOT gonna be
that person you know what that's a great
segue into our next story that I was
gonna bump up but now which is that MTV
cuts ties with Teen Mom star Jenelle
Evans that's what I'm talking about okay
MTV has cut ties with Teen Mom 2 star
Jenelle Evans after her husband David
Easton admitted to killing their family
dog last week quote MTV ended its
relationship with David Easton over a
year ago in February 2018 and is not
filmed with any new episodes of team on
2 with him since a spokesperson for the
network told page 6 in a statement on
Tuesday additionally we have stopped
filming with Jenna Eason as of April 6
2019 and have no plans to cover her
story in the upcoming season it's time
and you know what I don't even think
this is enough
what what what more could any show needs
to end show is so like negative and so
like making stupid people famous I agree
and I've not seen enough episodes to
even speak on it but in the five minutes
that I've seen in between episodes of
siesta key there seems to be one girl
who it seems like a sweetie is her
blonde hair and Mackenzie no she's not
Maisie Maisie yeah that's Maisie who
also who seems like she's done decent
things with her fame but there's another
girl who like got pregnant with her high
school at you know as she was a teen mom
I don't remember if they kept the baby
or if they gave up for adoption but her
and that boyfriend were like still
together
is he an addict I don't think so like I
think they were just like sweeties but I
only ever saw one episode is she
brunette with eye colors in her hair and
I think her name is like Katy or
something maybe yeah I like had to watch
one episode where this is so funny I had
to watch one episode of Teen Mom what I
did like when I hosted something on MTV
last year and they were like used to
talk about Teen Mom and I literally was
like talking to my ass because I had
seen one episode so I feel as if I know
a lot about it you know totally also
Teen Mom has been great for teenage
pregnancy cystic statistics do you know
that when it came on the air the teenage
pregnancy rate in America went down
because like girls cuz you want to look
like you want to have the life of
Jenelle right like girls saw the
consequences of you know of not using a
rubber
okay well they did their job now they
really they really need to go off there
and if we didn't have keen mom then we
would never
the UK version at teen mum that's a
thing
yes I love the UK version of MTV shows
Georgica sure have you ever heard of it
Jaggi
it's [ __ ] wild like they litter it's
literally a sex tape like it's the
wildest show the characters are like
they look like they dressed up as Snooki
for Halloween but like that's actually
what they look like it is the craziest
show like MTV UK is literally just like
a parody of MTV the people that I'm
talking about its name are Catelynn and
Tyler and they gave their baby up for
adoption it was very touching okay
that's the episode I thought so did they
continue on the show even though she
wasn't a teen mom I think so
like I think they continue to follow her
story again I do not know but anyways
Teen Mom that's where it's at totally
that is hilarious hilarious anyway just
so many reality shows that are just
fulfilling my life these days and I just
feel like Teen Mom I could really live
without for sure but like that's just
you know it's a bad rut girls is really
doing enough for me you know is it
though just like I don't know it's just
like the people are the show is in but
like following people are but you know
being Britney following Britney car
right on it sir Emma's given me enough
like seeing how she uses her bio clarity
skincare it's like it's enough for me
died a new tie a new you know she uses
bio clarity I started using bio clarity
1 cuz they sponsored the toast but to
because I saw Britney crazy and she did
so good it for her wedding theme when
they reached out I was like well it's
good enough everybody enough for asking
Cosmo like I think I think we didn't
swing this bio clarity is a clean and
green skincare brand that has products
that just work it's that time of year to
get back into healthier habits and
that's what healthy eating does for your
body bio clarity does for your face
their skincare line offers easy to use
regimens
with good for you ingredients that will
give you great skin what I love most
about bio clarity is like you know when
you look put on like a skin thing and
it's like white it's like natural
ingredients look like right like oh my
god excuse me
bio Clary actually looks like what's in
it you know right green it's like mud
like that's it's a I know it's working
cuz like that's like when you take a
vitamin and it's like pink look at how
right you know they're not adding the
things just for vanity bio-cop clarity
comes with everything you need to get
clear glowing skin three-step regimen
that gets rid of breakouts clears and
calm skin and is packed full of
detoxifying nutrients it's also an
tryouts
and includes a super special ingredient
only in bio bio clarity floral acts from
plants and that's exactly what it looks
like get healthier more radiant skin by
going to bio clarity calm and right now
for our listeners he will say 40% off on
skincare routines plus an additional 15%
off everything on their website it's an
incredible deal but you need to enter
our code toast at checkout go to bio
clarity comma get 40% off skincare
routines plus an additional 15% off
everything on their website when you use
our code toast exciting back to reality
TV now that I think about it it's been a
while since I started a new reality TV
show I guess other than siesta key but
now that it's not on you know my network
or whatever I can't even keep up with it
yeah but like outside of a new Real
Housewives franchise like I'm ready for
like a new great Rick Bravo reality show
Oh Bravo yeah any crooner of texicans
last night which I did Hana
Texico knows I didn't watch it but it's
trending on Twitter okay and they had
Mexican dynasty too and I've heard good
things about it but like I'm not
actually the opposite like I feel as if
my docket is truly full and it's
starting to become like when I wouldn't
I know Vanna pearls I saw doesn't like
oh cause like I have to watch it like
yeah it's feeling like it's borderlining
on a burden and I don't think I could
take on any more reality shows I
understand well texarkana doesn't count
because it started coming as the Real
Housewives of San Antonio and so it's
like it feels like another Real
Housewives franchise to me why don't you
start summer house cuz I'm not
interested like I feel like I've tried
and you know what like every time an
episode of like Vanderpump rules ends I
get the previously on summer house and
that seems like enough for me dying you
know I mean you have to be really
desperate to want to start summer house
but it sounded like you might have been
so no no no I'm okay okay I'm gonna do
let me know though are you ready for a
next story
exciting sports illustrated swimsuit
covers are out we have three cover stars
Tyra Banks Alex Morgan and Camille
kostik this is really exciting Sports
Illustrated swimsuit edition is always
exciting okay I love a three-fer I
always wonder why they do that though I
wonder why they do it I guess it's cause
like you know why have one when you can
have three but it also basically not
special for like the one person you know
definitely but it's like I was like
Ashley Graham was on it I was like this
is a moment for society and
no there's two others getting [ __ ] on
the other covers you know yeah I guess
it but for the person on the cover it's
like still you're on the cover of Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Edition
epic that Tyra Banks is on again and
Alice Morgan but like for Camille
classic basically this is also she looks
so good she's giving me like a very Kate
Upton like juicy luscious - it's fine
you know I wanted to say like and
something I don't think that Sports
Illustrated or a lot of I don't think
Sports Illustrated does a lot of like
unnatural looking window they don't but
it is just so refreshing even if we only
get it once a year to see a natural tit
on the cover of a magazine you know and
like never in my life have I felt like
compelled to grab someone's tits but
like in Kate Upton and now Camille's
like I just feel like grabbing their
tits like yes girl get those titties no
she looks incredible she looks so happy
she looks at herself did you watch a
video of her arm freckles and like arm
freckle representation is so important
oh my god that I have something else to
talk to about Ryan we have the word
representation and two minutes ago oh I
know what you're gonna say okay and then
also wait I had one more thing to say
that Camille um there's just so much no
did you watch a video of her fighting
idea it was like so cute my arm freckles
head chills it was really cute
I'm really happy for her like she's been
working at this for a while I love the
Tyra Banks cover like I love the
side-by-side like Tyra Banks looks good
she looks great I wanna say she argue
really looks better than the first time
she was on but I'm not here to pit women
against another or against their others
and Alex Morgan isn't athlete so like
she's just an athletic body and like I
feel like there's something for everyone
here and I think maybe that's why they
do tree yes I just think like the arc of
a Sports Illustrated cover is so
interesting like I just remember seeing
Sports Illustrated like when I was a kid
in like a pharmacy and thinking it was
like porn like it used to be like crazy
like boys like calendar and I think also
it was cuz we were kids like what do you
think back in the pictures it's just
women in swimsuits right maybe but I
think for a while it was like this kind
of almost like barstool like men smoke
house whatever they do and now it's
really weirdly like arced itself into
like this like platform for women ya
know it's a feminist platform it really
is
and in Camille's in like the description
of her they said like she's you know
beautiful and a model and everything but
she also really epitomizes what Sports
Illustrated is in 2019 they really feel
as though she does and I think she
deserves it and like a part of me
thought she would do it but I'm like no
she's
new I thought last year maybe like in
her first like that she would and then
it didn't happen and I never I didn't
think who's gonna be on the cover this
year but I think if I thought about it
long enough like this makes complete
sense and they usually don't know who
the cover star is and then I immediately
become obsessed with them like kind of
Davis said it know her like I'm
following and scram and we both wear the
same jacket once like it was amazing
also Kate Upton I didn't know who she
had some like who is this girl with the
huge tits no and like Kate Upton changed
my life she changed the industry and I
firmly believe like Camille Kasich is
gonna change a lot of girls lives and
yeah I'm so excited for it I love her
body I love what it you know same I like
love her body aspiring to a body like
had it I think it's so healthy and
mutual and I love looking at it I love
looking at her and I'm really happy for
her
me too I just I really do love Sports
Illustrated consistently and they you
know they under promise to never
delivered yeah and also like I feel like
there wasn't there hasn't been so much
lead up to this cover and I it came out
kind of late this year because like last
year came out in February so I'm just
curious like what was going on over
there but it came out late and I don't
know if it's late I just did it make so
much hype around it usually it's like
they'll put the cover and blur at the
Facebook who is oh yeah yeah yeah but
they've really had so many iconic covers
like member Nina Agdal Chrissy Teigen
and it's like all turning around their
toys she's in the sand yeah cute another
three thir
yeah but it was all on one cover right
but that's cool too very cool yeah
another constantly innovating and they
did three covers with Kate Upton three
of her three of her in different pockets
and then I got them autograph
they said them to me cuz they know I'm a
big fan so if anyone's watching I'll
take some more autographs maybe terrible
take a smell one - I'll take a chameleon
- but I feel like I can thank me later
you know I was like really like I'm so
proud I'm like honestly a little jealous
but still proud ya know but like I need
to learn how to be like happy for other
people without thinking about myself cuz
like the second I saw this this morning
I was like oh my god
I know the cover of the Sports
Illustrated model and I was like happy
for myself know for sure but I think
that's that's normal and you know what I
think it's it's brave of you to admit
that like you know you're thinking that
you're be always I'm like okay like I
would think the same thing what I think
is like I'm really hard like it should
have got a key
I would rather drive in me on the cover
of a magazine in the bathing silly if
Sports Illustrated came to you no I
totally do it cuz they were totally like
retouching form you know but
not likely fit normal retouching like my
skin and my teeth like not like my waist
okay you know like the normal like
mustache yeah trying to tell me that one
of those women on the beach out of
sweaty mustache I don't know maybe they
have like a mustache together yeah oh so
they feel like really cold climates most
of the time so they're definitely not
sweaty yeah cuz in a cold climate like
your body's shrivels up and like you
actually look skinnier definitely that's
why when I'm when I'm cold all my rings
fall off I'm sweating right now I can't
get these [ __ ] off I know everyone's
like in the summer you might want to get
your rings bigger like yeah honestly
yeah the-- crazy
okay well exciting for everyone involved
just a great day for women o
representation okay I don't know if you
know but you did hear about this new
James Charles controversy hoarse hi guys
so you know what's so funny I was
thinking about bringing it up against ur
day cuz I was like you know we're this
Instagram capturing that like minutes
seem like he was talking about himself
as a minority but okay so if you don't
know there's like another James Charles
controversy and like I hate to bring it
out because like I actually really like
him and I don't think it anyway he meant
to be like malicious I think he was just
like stupid about it but he put he got
to go to the Met Gala which is like a
crazy big deal and he put a caption on
his Instagram of a picture of him at the
McCallum was just like I'm so excited
like I really can't believe it I'm just
like excited to be an influencer
represented in the media you know think
this is a great moment for influencer
representation in the media right the
way that someone would talk about like
Asian representation or african-american
like he was talking about himself as of
like a minority that influencers are an
oppressed minority right it was just
like a really weird way of phrasing it
let me see if you left it yeah being
invited to such an important event like
the Met Ball is such an honor and a step
forward in the right direction for
influential representation in the media
and I am so excited to be a catalyst
okay like first of all step in the right
direction acts like we're like fighting
civil rights like it is a very weird way
to say but this is just like hilarious
like testament to how it like serious
influencers take themselves ya know it
was it was so extra much like him but
yeah there's so many better ways to say
that yeah I just seems like there's such
a spotlight on him and like I feel like
people are really unfair to him like and
I don't know the history of all he
apparently is a command with a thousand
controversies but it started following
him for the past couple months yeah I've
started following for the past couple
nights like people make a mountain out
of a molehill a mountain out of a
molehill when it comes to him like about
everything and it's like a little unfair
but again I don't know the
the history of the beginning of like how
he became this whatever but I thought he
became James Charles because he posted
his graduation his yearbook photos went
viral yeah but no then and then he was
the first male covergirl huh but
something happened I think hit tweets
actually um that like canceled him but
he really he came back like huge but
ever since head he said just had like a
million little things like people like
hate him before really people just
really want to see him other than people
that love him and he has like so many
subscribers and fans but the people that
don't subscribe to him literally and
physically um just like want to see you
know down you know I mean I was reading
the replies to like one of the news
articles that was like he's getting a
lot of flack for this cancellation for
this representation statement and every
single one was like cancelled he never
started he can't be canceled kidding but
like his literally his YouTube he is
like a million new followers a week he
never started like get your head out of
your ass
no so like every as much as I think it's
funny to like like make fun of that
caption because it was really [ __ ]
stupid it must be hard for him to get
everything he says picked apart but like
it's annoying because the like you know
that's what it's like to be an
influencer represented in the media
that's one his cross to bear yeah and to
like knowing that everyone's gonna take
what you say and make a mountain out of
a molehill even if it is just a molehill
don't give them a mountain with
influence or representation in the media
yes you're so oppressed
yeah you know it was a stupid thing and
when people come after you so much that
you have to be a little bit more self
aware than making a caption like that
yeah ever since I was personally kids
think that's his version of self-aware
and like that's concerning yeah yeah
okay I just wanted to bring up I thought
it was a funny anecdote a you know it is
jafer influenced their representation in
media and I do understand what he was
trying to say which is he was being
taken seriously right influence her
inclusion yeah sorry though influencer
participation yeah artistic Asian he's
consistently putting his foot in his
mouth and he like meat so like get some
media training yeah okay you know not
the biggest deal in the world speaking
of someone who's just wonderful Kim
Kardashian quietly funded the fight to
free seventeen federal inmates I heard
Kim Kardashian quietly bankrolled a
successful campaign to free seventeen
federal inmates serving life sentences
for low-level drug crime crimes over the
past three months sources said Tuesday
funded by the reality TV stars deep
pockets legal eagles Britney K Barnett
of the buried alive project and
Angelle Cody of the D car serration
collective secured the release of the
prisoners as a part of a campaign called
90 days of freedom those free with
Kardashians helped include Terence Byrd
convicted in 1995 of a possession with
intent to sell less than a kilo of crack
cocaine or as the Buried Alive project
puts it in a profile of Byrd quote about
enough to fill a small sandwich bag he
was 26 when he was locked up and spent
about half his life in a Cell before he
was freed and reunited with his family
in addition to Kardashian's funding the
prisoners emancipation was made possible
by the first step jock the speaking the
sweeping criminal justice reform bill
signed into law by President Trump late
last year the bill had bipartisan
congressional support along with the
backing of Kardashian and her husband
rapper an avowed Trump and Kanye West
criminal justice reform has become a
cause close to Kardashian's heart in
recent years culminating in her trip to
the White House in May 2018 to
successfully lobby Trump to commute the
sentence of Alice Murray Johnson is
precious gem of a woman a Tennessee
grand man that great-grandmother
sentenced to life for nonviolent drug
conviction oh my god I just like I'm
loved Kim so much and she's like oh is
shocking me and it was reading some of
the replies to and like people are just
consistently like letting me down
people are like because it's where were
you beating their pies Twitter okay well
no but this is like the the consensus of
Twitter and it's important to know what
people are saying it's like well if she
did in secret why are we hearing about
it I hate what people like devalue the
charitable or like the good things that
celebrities do because like if it's in
the news I hit the wrong research doing
it it's now it's tainted like when
Taylor gave like 150 thousand dollars to
that like um LGBTQ organization in
Tennessee to like fight whatever bill
was trying to be passed people are like
well she's like why is it and I sweetly
like shut the [ __ ] up the money still
counts idiot 11 11 make a wish I wish
people would stop being such [ __ ]
idiots
totally great wish so like so is the 17
prisoners do they have to go back to
jail now because we found out about it
in the press you stupid it doesn't undo
that like the the righteous or like
charitable thing someone did so just
like shut the [ __ ] off oh and also in
Kim's case like the say she freed Alice
Marie Johnson we never heard about it
and the work is still down like the her
putting that on the show and like in her
Instagram and us following this journey
like I now feel compelled that
nonviolent drug crimes you shouldn't
serve a life sentence which are you I
know I had no education about this what
she's educating people you know as
someone who is relatively in her own
world I am now learning of all the
prison reform that needs to go down in
this country right and like with someone
like yeah maybe you know you couldn't
turn on c-span and learn more of it but
we're watching for dashians and they're
giving us our candy with our broccoli no
I love Kim I'm just I'm consistently
proud of her that's it this is wonderful
I saw something somewhere like maybe
they were filming this for some sort of
special which like great cool like my
bars more education so this is really
incredible and it's like she even before
we learned about this like she's truly
like the busiest woman in the world and
like and this is the text Kanye was was
saying crazy getting people out of jail
and so now what is she up to 19 people
that guy Matthew Ellis 17 like she's
changed 19 people's lives and then an
exponential on a factor like to law
school like [ __ ] off you know why when I
think about how much like I was actually
thinking this morning about how people
have been making fun of Kim and Kanye
like for so long like when they did that
music video and Seth Rogen like as a
joke did like whatever like people have
just been making fun of them for so long
like I can't imagine if that was me like
how I wouldn't have literally just quit
and like moved to Iowa and like just
gotten a regular job and like starting
my life over like they get made fun of
so much like sometimes they deserve to
be made fun of blood sometimes like
people just find like the craziest
things like get mad at her for it or
make fun of her for like I'm really not
here for it and I feel like in the past
when people have made fun of her thing
oh she's laughing all the way the debate
to the bank but I feel like now with
this stuff of people making fun of her
it's like she's laughing all the way to
sleeping better at night all the way to
Ted
totally to the saying Evan there's no
nothing Kim's getting nothing out of
this other than pure joy and helping
people the fact that there are people
who can actually find a way to like make
this negative is so shocking I didn't
want to focus on them just wanna focus
on the positive philanthropic ventures
of one Kimberly Noel kardashian-west
agreed completely she's laughing all the
way to heaven yeah that's a great place
to be totally I'll see you there
okay fit inside this story little
business
you know to shake things up uber drivers
will go on strike over pay and benefits
ahead of the company's 90 billion dollar
IPO today you know I heard about this
and I kind of support it you heard about
it yeah here are the key points
according to CNBC which you know I trust
CM easy because they gave a shark tank
and the prophet and the prophet in
Spanish do you watch my screen
have fun hilarious ride hailing drivers
are planning to strike on Wednesday the
protests low wages as uber prepares to
follow lift on to the public market
drivers have been saying for years that
the services pay too little and unfairly
avoid offering additional benefits by
classifying them as contractors instead
of full-time employees are good both
uber and lyft have offered rewards to
their most active and long-standing
drivers as part of their IPOs the strike
comes just two days ahead of louvers IPO
which is expected to be the largest
among new tech stocks debuts this year
with an expected valuation of 80 point
five three billion dollars to 91.5 one
billion dollars on a fully diluted basis
no that is so crazy and you know what I
need I'm like the most annoying uber
passenger like most the time I want to
be spoken to but sometimes I'm just like
interested about the like the lives of
uber drivers like do you drive for lyft
you drive for uber Lake in New York it's
very much an uber city but if you drive
for lyft like when you get like a ten
dollar ride as a lyft driver you get
like seven out of ten dollars
I think we're driver you get like five
it's like the Commission's are so loving
it always when I'm like this is this
your full-time job that I care and like
they have to get their own car they pay
for their own guys they don't have any
benefits like you're a full-time and
play for a company that like virtually
pretends you don't exist like when they
try and get a contact like if there's a
situation or like there's an error in
their payment or ever like to get in
contact with like an uber customer
service rep as a driver it's virtually
impossible and honestly I can't believe
there hasn't been a strike long longer
before this cuz like when we were in
high school the cab drivers used to
always go on strike but it's like your
government I think are you a government
employee as a cab driver no but there
there is more of like a cushion and more
benefit when you are a cab driver like
for uber like they literally leave you
out on your own and so you get it crash
into the nubret driver they're like go
[ __ ] yourselves
yes you know I agree with most of what
you said but I think Luber has made
being a driver so much more accessible
than in the ways of the cab days where
you had to get at cab medallion which
would cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars just to be able to drive and
then they start
you at $7.50 now before that before the
cab driver eating its paint yeah so I
think the cab model is really [ __ ] up
and getting even worse and I think
that's why drivers and people turn to
Ober in the first place but I do think
there's a big gap in terms of people who
drive for uber full-time and this is
their full-time job like they should be
able to get benefits and some sort of
just like structure from burnin uber is
like a 21st century company like the
uber corporate people like they get PTO
and maternity leave and benefits and
like they work less hours than the
actual full-time uber driver right so I
think there needs to be justice her
full-time uber drivers but I think some
of the perks of ubirr is that you can do
it as a side household you know so many
times that you talk to it's their side
job they're their students here at
school I agree if you work a certain
amount of hours a week if you work under
like 20 hours a week like as an uber
driver that's a part-time job like if
you're working out here forty ups
anymore seven days a week like that's a
full-time job yeah and why why don't you
get any sort of reward or benefit from
being an uber employee but some idiot
intern who works in marketing does right
I totally agree they need to do better
by their drivers who do really well by
them you know and like are making uber
the company it's just that's valued at
[ __ ] 90o company like Margo is now
applying for jobs like she's like go to
all these like startup Millennials like
we have retreats and like they read snap
yeah they're kind of to like make their
employees feel like family and it's like
if you're not a team player like we
don't watch it was like uber is one of
these now like 21st century millennial
companies startup tech companies where
it's like will take you ever treat will
pay for your grad school like they do
all this [ __ ] except for the driver
it's like what's up yeah and like see
drivers are that's why this company I'm
gonna check - yeah no actually I gotta
get to my meeting later but so in my
heart a monster I guess I'm like it took
them so long to give the capability to
tip in the uber app like [ __ ] you like
that is kick yeah totally it's [ __ ]
like I'm here for the strike I'm yeah
I'm here for the strike to uber
like uber has is fraught with issues and
also add Buber corporate where it's like
you know free snacks and nap pods they
also had like a huge problem with like
super Nashville and like just like a
boys club mentality today yeah and they
brought in like new management
management and I think it's gotten
better and they're always trying to like
show how they've gotten better but you
know what I think you need to do better
you know and where does this great
company where it's like super beneficial
in a million ways while also being
deeply problematic like they are
struggling with this again you see
someone posed as an uber driver and
raped a passenger in the Delaware or
something like terrible they their front
with problems there but they're also
doing great things for like drunk
driving I have to imagine that since
ride-sharing happened like the
statistics of people drunk driving has
to have gone down significantly like
there's no way
definitely so it's like let's let's
let's balance it out and you talk to so
many drivers who are so grateful for
uber because they're able to like go to
school and work and and work on their
hours and like make their own hours and
it really isn't there's something
entrepreneurial bad for the drivers but
they too need benefits and it it's it's
not just it just NHS and then jodan got
me people are talking about the cab
driver medallions now someone's like I
can't even that's a whole another yeah
actually the honorable thing that's
going on in New York City yesterday
though oh my god I took further he has
drivers
I shouldn't over this morning and on
loud was like this AM radio station it
was like City Hall like this open forum
about whether Bill DeBlasio should run
for president and while I thought it to
be mind-numbing ly boring it was
actually quite interesting because he
was full of interesting facts yes they
had this audience and audience was like
full of just random New Yorkers and they
were like raise your hand if you voted
for Bill DeBlasio more than once cuz
he's now been twice so most of people
raise their hand and it was also like
raise your hand if you would vote for
Bill de Blasio for president and
literally not one person raised a hand
isn't crazy yeah and it was just like
all these people calling in and it got a
little less interesting like as these
like morons we're calling in just like
giving their opinions on de Blasio and
like we should run for president but um
I didn't know to build a wall to it was
running for president but I'm here to
endorse the fact that he shouldn't know
totally I didn't know this was even in
the cards for him um but now yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be a no for me only
and it's like yeah what was on last
night Oh Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills Beverly Hills I caught up on New
York so oh my god I just want to talk
about in New York really quickly are you
caught up no but it's on tonight so can
we recap of tomorrow oh for sure but
like my jaw was on the floor at totally
identities breakdown with her model
there's something about the circus first
of all we have to go to the circus and
like you should be the ring man no it
looked on you have to
so I'm not here for the circus for a
multitude of reasons one is because they
use animals for entertainment and even
though they're like rescue animals and
like Ben I literally left a comment on
Dorinda and sternum I'm like please
don't partner with the circus like they
abused animals
she's like their rescue animals what
does that even mean like just because
they're rescued a desert scene in the
circuits like it makes no sense like
they're being rehabilitated in the
circus I'm not here for it and I will
not be at the circus okay nor will I be
supporting this particular venture for
The Real Housewives of New York I need
to do a little research on the Big Apple
Circus and learn more about the animals
and what they do and whether or not it's
natural and I also will just need a
documentary about it to tell me what to
think
yeah and then I'll make my decision
totally but let's do New York tomorrow
cuz I'm okay I'll watch Ted Earley Hills
Beverly Hills okay so I made a tweet
that I thought was gonna break the
Internet I saw the tweet before I
watched the episode and that was my
cross to bear so when I read this tweet
I'm literally looking at bed I like that
you were being then I'm about to break
[ __ ] into that because I didn't
realize I thought the big RV that they
had it said skylight on the side I
thought that was just like the RV
company I thought it looks it sounds
like an outdoors like company I know
ease yeah so then as they're driving
into skyline security calm on the bottom
I'm like oh my god this is Teddy his
husband's company I'm like else they're
taking a book out of their agency's the
chicken patient of the agency's book
this but like the agency has been doing
it subtly for years until like he built
up the agency and now you see it
everywhere it's just any concern this is
so overt so heavy-handed and it's like I
and Lisa Rinna said something or tweeted
something recently where it's like
people come on this show and then
promote their ventures all the time some
of us have booked some of us have TV
shows you see that QVC fitness empires
whatever and but if we're being used to
promote a whole new show Vanderpump dogs
that was the conspiracy at the time like
we should be getting a cut of that agree
and it's like how does she feel riding
around in a branded RV like this and
says if you want to use your own private
you know one-on-one time with your
husband to promote your company totally
other stuff but like I was just curious
like did the women not feel some type of
way they just being like totally like
fabulous by this RV thing yeah no it was
it was a little too obvious but whatever
everyone seemed to be fine with it if
anyone was gonna say something it was
Camille cuz she was like coming for
[ __ ] teddy she's being such a she's
annoying me so much I'd really want her
off the show and I haven't
and I just want to say it in case it
happens I think that next season Camille
Grammer will be a full-time housewife
really and she will get that as a reward
for her loyalty to Lisa Vanderpump
oh that's what we talked we said that oh
did we yeah we said what's the only way
that Lisa would come back if she has an
ally that she can I'm saying Lisa or not
it's apparent that like Camille is
starting to be swayed to be like anti
Lisa but something happens because she
like went Evander from content opening
she keeps apologizing on Twitter for the
T thing like she's like really like
eating uh Lisa Vanderpump's but so I
think that she's being promised a
full-time role because I swear to god
all camille Grammer once in this life is
to be back on the show and every time
she gets a minute on camera time she
tries to say the most obscene absurd
crazy things make this huge mush but so
she can be relevant and I'm still not
here to feeding her because she's so
annoying here's the thing about Camille
that's that's curious to me like 50% of
the time on the show she's saying like
what needs to be said like when Teddy
was interjecting with Derrida and Kyle
like Camille Steph Tim was like Cuddy
and in a you know referee sort of way
like no one had to read side and like
sometimes she's saying what like someone
needs to say but other times she's just
completely starting [ __ ] and just
totally when she when they are having
like the greatest time and then they
just move over and she starts she brings
up PK to Kyle like no [ __ ] off like yeah
and then and then she ends the
conversation and like she shuts it down
by saying what needs to be said like
it's you never know what you're gonna
like she's it's really frustrating she
annoys me so much I'm sorry I'm like so
rooting for her and then other times I'm
like what are you what is you doing
there were just so many moments of the
episode though that I just really
enjoyed I'm really loving Denise
Richards like she really turned it
around for me she was just being so
funny and cute I'm loving doing these
Richards
she is earning her four million dollar
contract by base by being an open book
like you want to know about Charlie she
tell me about Charlie she wouldn't know
about her life now just talking about
her like about a hand jobs right and
it's like the way that women were like
giggling and talking about like the
happy endings things it's like yeah it's
like a funny subject it was kind of
annoying me like don't young someone's
ya know I couldn't agree more and then
they wouldn't let it go like the next
morning on the bus Kim you know if I
want to do that I mean Denise if I
looked at my happy I'm gonna go like
this no and like she's being such a team
player by not like
getting annoyed by it and anyone would
like laugh at it in the moment whatever
like hit
the endings are funny think Calvin
Harris lol yeah but at a certain point
like I would just be like shut like was
it like anything else like girls like
calm down you know she has a high
threshold that they were acting like
actual teenagers they were acting like
twelve-year-old yeah and it was just
annoying me on behalf of her the gleb
being like looked really fun that I
could sing that okay by the way that was
not the camping I had expected like I
had him in I thought they were gonna be
sleeping in tents on the floor I would
never expect that or asked them to do
that that sounds horrible
no but I thought like it looked in
chronic so glam like so Beverly Hills
not like something not it was more glam
than like Teddy's beach house trip was
totally like and because it was
seriously glam ya know it looked really
good I place around here I would love to
do that I think we should I think that
we should too and like the beer excuse
me the beer pong like looked so cute and
fun and what Kyle said to such a
pertinent things last night's words the
end of episode one that like it's trips
like this that really for its like
strong relationships between the women
because you're like it's different than
a cocktail party later you're seeing
each other like it's like camp with your
your relationship with your cameron's is
different than the relationship with
your school friends yeah they're just
seeing each other between the halls no
it's like you're getting showering
together go to breakfast together you're
seeing each other words that make up
like you're vulnerable like I'm the 24
hours like it's definitely someone
farted like you know it's just like it's
so real and and I think that a lot of
the relationships will be changed
because of this tray I agree and to that
I don't know how they started talking
about like body types and like just
self-image some confidence that was so
image she said exactly what we say on
the show probably like once a month
which is at the Kardashians and JLo and
I believe Demi Lovato also are really
changing like what it means to be like a
beautiful woman yeah someone will come
in right in certain like your ass looks
big and she's like that's a compliment
be like in the early 2000s like that was
like known in when Lisa Rinna they were
like yeah our daughters don't feel so
much pressure to be thin like as I did
growing up yeah and and then they all
like chimed in on in like had the exact
same experience and I thought that was a
wildly interesting conversation I
thought it was well because it's like
they're they're the pinnacle of like
Hollywood and glamour and like and
staying young and beautiful and it's
like so I want to hear from them on what
they think like industry standards are
right and they have the exact same
opinions as us which is that like it's
getting you know it's always gonna be
difficult for women like just judging
yourself you're
your own harshest critic but it's
getting a little bit better and like the
role models that we have now are like
making it you know just more easier to
be a woman I agree I liked that
conversation I liked it too it was the
second thing that kind of snow that was
the first thing was that they forged
stronger relationships like this you
know I just thought it was like a great
episode like where nothing really
happened except oh my god what did they
just shove the scene of Lisa Vanderpump
cleaning her kitchen in the beginning or
with the marble is so stupid
oh my god it's so stupid next week on
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills Lisa
shows John says to her kitchen which by
the way is only showing to me that she
has a very close relationship with the
John's right just further conflicting
what she said in the beginning of the
season which she said they just work her
it was so it's so stupid but like I
guess it fit I guess if she didn't film
she would literally be gone except she's
having lunch with Camille next week or
something like she would literally not
be in the season if she wasn't filming
her kitchen right that's crazy it really
bothers me when they're all sitting
around and they bring up Lisa Vanderpump
and it's like that gives her so much joy
and they're fighting and that let me
read that it was like a brilliant moment
by Camille where she was like this woman
is like ruining really like it's like
your own alien ships with her a ruin and
now it's infiltrating our great control
taking our group it's bleeding out like
we're having the best time and like
still this thing is like you know she's
being who said Oh Demi I'm The Bachelor
she's being like the cancer of the group
where it's like it's affecting
everything it's spreading and like that
was a moment by Camille where I'm like
yes like thank you because someone needs
to say and also Erika said it where it's
like I don't care about someone wants to
be an [ __ ] I care about the women
here yeah and like they must stop
talking about Lisa marrow from when
she's not there because it gives her
haters and gives gives her supporters
and her like so much work with him it's
like you can't stop talking about her
when she's not there there she's all you
guys have like you know and it makes
them look bitter agreed and I think
derice only one who's like when she
talks about it she just comes from a
place of sadness but I wish she could be
here I miss her like I love her there's
definitely something odd with the PKM at
all like why he's so reluctant to like
let the friendship go I don't know why
it's effli he's like a business thing
but like at that dinner he was being
like excuse me can recap last week he
was being like so thirsty and just being
like Lisa was literally being Kyle
called it she was like she will hold
your friendship as hostage until you
apologize or agree with her so literally
this is sitting there
I cannot be your friend unless you admit
that I didn't do it she's Australian oh
by the way I thought that that lunch
like who made Lisa look so bad and like
a two-year-old but PK was a groveling
sick oh why oh why we believe it did to
your other and also like a manipulator
and PK said he was like it's like you
guys want to control our thought yeah
and it wasn't about me do it more the
children's lives again yeah that he
believed her because like a normal
person would but until you realize like
nobody says anything in Lisa van from
swearing under children's eyes ya know
it was it was such an odd dinner and I
can't understand like the PK part of it
and then like him getting himself
involved with the Kyle thing like stop
yes being his first season member season
1 PK he had no but he was being a Kamil
to me where it's like some of the things
he was saying was like yes you're trying
to control our thoughts what are you
doing and then I'm the other hand he's
saying things were it's like sit down ya
know it's crazy how people can have like
such a moments of like true clarity and
like genius and then also be so stupid
but I think in the in his first season
he was a hundred percent stupid and now
he's 50/50 it was getting better right
right they all looked so cute like with
their little camping outfits and like
they really all of all this the
franchise it's like they're the only
franchise that I watch them like I like
shop for bags oh my god totally you know
yeah even though I can't afford them no
but maybe I can't on thredUP it's the
world's largest online consignment and
thrift store with up to 90% off
estimated retail price they had over
50,000 new items every day at unbeatable
prices shop all your favorite brands
from the comfort of your couch made well
from $9 anthropology from $13 coach from
25 and Nike from $6 everything is hand
inspected and triple check to ensure
it's high-quality condition so that
makes it super easy to shop customize
your experience and see only items in
your size style and price range so I
went on literally after watching The
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills cuz I
was just feeling inspired so like act
like a housewife but at like a peasant
price and that's exactly what I did I
just I sorted by designer handbags and I
went out I got myself a new bag Oh
exciting yeah from the racks to your
door never pay full price again and shop
guilt-free a thread up visit thread up
comm slash toast today for an extra
thirty percent off your first order
that's thread up thre DUP comm slash
toast for 30 percent off your first
order no a and their thread up comm
slash toast for an extra thirty percent
off today thr IDI u P comm slash toast
extra thirty percent off I love throw it
up because I love design
I just Beach baggage baggage bag a
peasant price and a peasant price and I
love shopping secondhand like first of
all you got things that you might not
ever be able to purchase and it's good
for the world viral in the environment
which is just such a bonus I think they
have like star style at a to start
budget tota I feel like leo
when I'm on throw that whose thing in
the world exactly so we have a New York
tonight I really like need to either
have you watch Real Housewives of
Atlanta or find a co-host one day like
who does because I am just fraught with
anxiety and they need to talk to someone
about it and maybe maybe I can maybe you
can help me because there's a scene this
season where the women are going into
Nene's clock they watch your story so I
have some background okay so there's
this moment where it's like the kind of
the peak of the season where like they
don't have a lot of footage but it's
like Nene runs in like grabs the
producer by the shoulders tears his
shirt just to get the women out of her
closet so they don't film and it would
seem like they have no video or audio
from that moment because like the next
thing you know it's like she pulled the
producer and then it's the next morning
so I was like are they to put the
cameras down or something and then last
last thing I was watching the part three
of the you reunion where they finally
started talking about this moment cuz
it's like the pinnacle of the season and
they're showing unseen footage and
there's like a lot of like
miscommunication between the women about
what went down that night but it seems
like they have a lot of footage and
audio of what actually did happen that
they're reluctant to to show so part of
me is thinking like they're protecting
Nene because she's going through a hard
time but like no one gets protected on
Housewives doesn't Eenie or there's a
lot of footage at literary involves the
crew and the crew didn't sign up they
don't wanna be on camera they don't want
to be on TV like getting punched by a
woman interesting well I didn't watch
the season but that's actually the only
storyline I'm familiar with because I
watched that clip and then I watched the
finale episode where they talked about
what happened and then great you said to
me apparently Nene was chumming on
Porsha is pregnant look apparently Nene
pulled Porsha from the back ripped her
belt off and she fell forward and Marlo
there have audio of Marla being like
Samba tooth pregnant like so there's a
lot that happened that were not seen but
it also seems like they have a lot of
what happened why wouldn't they show it
to us okay
so my thoughts would be cuz when I first
saw just when they put on TV I was like
I'm totally with Nene like don't like it
she overreacted a little bit the cutting
of the shirt but whatever yeah she
pulled a producer shirt but if she's
pushing pregnant women like we have
another problem
but you're saying allegedly she pulled
the belt off in Porsha
stomach and then we do confirm Marlowe
said stop she's pregnant and then on the
reunion Marlowe was like I was just
playing being like Nene relax she's
pregnant
yeah which it could which is a very
possible thing the women have the women
are like no she look fully like kandi
said it they said like she put her hands
on Porsha well I guess if they have the
footage you're not gonna air it because
it's like like cereal they've equipped
you've seen of Nene from a couple
seasons ago reprimanding Porsha she said
Porsha you cannot put your hands on
people on camera and Porsha is like Nene
you put your hands on people all the
time I mean it's like what I've ever
seen footage of it well I think it's
like you don't see footage of it because
it's something that like could cause a
lawsuit and the women aren't allowed to
sue each other the house if you're a
housewife you can't sue another
housewife really that's why it doesn't
really happen that up and until you're
no longer house either Krupa Brenda go
right so I think if we're on TV it would
become like a whole thing that would
require a loss at night I don't think
Bravo wants to open themselves up to the
fact that those women are in contracts
where they can't even protect themselves
yeah let's just make you say yeah no I
was just like a little when I saw this
unseen footage I'm like what the [ __ ] I
think I really had no footage of the
Colombian boat extravaganza and they
kept using the same one clip of Ramona
sitting under a table right it's like
that would be like I've had the reunion
they finally showed unseen footage of
them on the boat freaking out throwing
up you know they didn't have it yeah it
was just weird I think it might it might
be like - I might be that bad that they
can't show it without opening themselves
up - like how could you let this happen
that's crazy I don't know it's just and
I definitely think there's a level of
protecting meaning because she is like
such a cornerstone she had made the
franchise's in network yeah I agree
she made the franchise into what it is
mm-hmm just that was interesting that is
interesting I watched our reunion part
of maybe I'll have some additional
thoughts but that's just me I just it's
honestly such a good show and I'm really
feeling like perplex like is Eva
broke and a liar or she really just like
misunderstood I can't tell why why do
they think that I watched her wedding
and I just thought she was so beautiful
yeah they know but like Marlo and Nene
like got some info from like her
bridesmaid who like ended up hating her
and like they say like her house was
repossessor
I was repossessed she has a new house
she has to move and like it is all a
little shady I think that's just a day
in the life for the housewives like it's
all you know diamonds and rose eh yeah
but it's really just cubic zirconium and
and boxed wine right no and like Kim
Crawford but like stone and so I love
Kim I'm sorry I'm sorry it's my favorite
sound I just I can't decide like if the
curtain really was like it was all a
facade and like she's a big fake
fraudster or like all the lies that
she's telling are actually the truth and
like justice for Eva I think all the
Housewives live above their means means
and means and it's a representation of
America we're just all living above our
means ourselves included well speaking
of living above our means we got to go
to a meeting which will hopefully stop
that so thank you guys for being here
thank you guys again for an amazing
presale yesterday if you are a pitcher I
remember you have until Friday Fridays
when the mayhem begins again so you have
until Friday to just like secure your
tickets Friday public on sell begins for
all the shows we're hitting up awesome
ringing up San Francisco San Diego Las
Vegas East Coast is Seattle Portland
West Coast the whole thing so yeah girl
go job Jack home mmm we'll see you guys
tomorrow bye have a great time
you